I'm I'm from Pittsburgh originally um
well I know it's less than two hours
away we have guests a haunted house we
think they're zombies involved I
actually brought some weapons with me so
there's probably gonna be 5 profile
loading player info identify player
Justine ezarik
we can start playing Marco Polo Marco
oh gosh where's the other two
straight-up reality like really didn't
know what we were doing so I had so much
food and then stashed inside of my
pockets so I played a lot of video games
so the first thing that I do whenever
I'm playing I will eat every single body
so the first body that I saw I was like
flipping its clothes off to try to find
a gun gamezone's election prison
experience in minor system failures
well I'm Justine we're all infected
subjects must not be allowed to escape